I see dead people
it may be hard to believe it's been 20
years since the sixth sense gave chills
to moviegoers but the sleeper hit was
just one of many achievements that had
critics Halen in 1999 has a
revolutionary year in film that same
year Sam Mendes delivered American
Beauty
a biting satire about suburban life that
won the Oscar for Best Picture
don't interrupt me honey and George
Lucas's much-anticipated Star Wars The
Phantom Menace topped the box office
taking in over a billion dollars
worldwide you do not talk about Fight
Club also released provocative dramas
like fights Ricky was a in Stanley
Kubrick's final film Eyes Wide Shut
by grabthar's hammer by the sons of war
van I shall avenge you humor also made
its mark in 1999 with a Star Trek parody
Galaxy Quest the coming-of-age comedy
American Pie and office space I gotta
get out of here I think I'm gonna lose
it
uh-oh sounds like somebody's got a case
of the Mondays director Mike judges
Comics end up of cubicle culture which
became a cult classic
Malkovich and there were cinematic game
changers like Spike Jonze is quirky
Being John Malkovich free and the matrix
a groundbreaking sci-fi epic now the new
book best movie year ever
how 1999 blew up the big screen looks at
what went into all of it and with us now
is Bryan Raftery author of best movie
year ever all about the films of 1999
published by our own Simon & Schuster a
division of CBS Brian good morning good
morning thank you for having me oh
absolutely well you know Prince said it
best we're gonna party like it's 1999
every day in every way so why was this a
great year in film well obviously I mean
you just saw a lot of movies I mean look
at the matrix or Fight Club or Being
John Malkovich or The Sixth Sense you
can go on and on all within 12 months of
each other which is an amazing lineup
but another thing about 1999 is that it
was kind of the peak era of movie going
I mean back then we did not have the
Internet in our phones you know in our
pockets for 24 hours a day there was not
200 TV shows we to catch up on so movies
were kind of the top of pop culture so
you would go to the theaters on Friday
because he wanted to talk about it on
Monday yeah what do you think came
together in that year to give us so many
great movies like this I think there are
a couple things one is that the industry
was really kind of burning out on
sequels and franchises and TV
adaptations and they really needed
something new yeah and they found it in
this really amazing group of filmmakers
who came from independent movies they
came from MTV that came from commercials
and they the big studios basically
handed these people a lot of money and
said okay go make your crazy movie about
the matrix whatever that is and I think
also the fact that you know y2k was kind
of looming that year and if you look at
and we all sort of joked about y2k now
but it it was this really scary deadline
and we're all kind of thinking wait
what's going on with the road are we
moving too fast and if you look at
movies like even a movie like office
space which is about liberating
stuff from your job and I figure out who
you are these movies are asking very big
questions with these really big stars
and these kind of really kind of
dangerous interesting ideas a huge gone
with the wind fan which was 1930 knowing
how much respect that you're getting
1969 also what is the difference is
there one key difference why you said 99
is better than those
well it's interesting cuz so you have
1939 you have gone with the wind you
have the Wizard of Oz you have
stagecoach and then 30 years later you
get this kind of really this upsurge of
young Hollywood with Easy Rider Midnight
Cowboy and I think what happened in 1909
was both of those kind of movies came
together you had these big big studio
spectacles like The Phantom Menace or
The Matrix and you also had like these
very personal very kind of very indie
movies being made in the studio system
so you sort of got the best of those two
worlds so maybe it's a 30 year cycles
did you actually watch and what did you
base your criteria
I watched almost all the way sir I mean
at least 50 to 75 of these movies and I
watched the ones I covered four or five
times I mean I would get up at very
early the morning yeah great it's fun
I'd have to get up early the morning
before my kids got up to put on the
matrix of five o'clock so you know I
talked to almost 100 people or so and so
you kind of want to be on your game and
remember every where you're talking to
Edward Norton about Fight Club you want
to know as much about fight clubs
everywhere and do you see a lot of these
movies were game changers and
particularly it was interesting Star
Wars Episode one which critically was
not her he's not exactly lauded right
but really did change the industry in a
lot of ways it did I mean we all sort of
were so used now like the Avengers are
coming out in a few weeks we're so used
to these big franchise movies coming out
now at once a month or twice a month if
there hadn't been a Star Wars movie in
in more than fifteen years at that point
and that was after Titanic the biggest
movie of the 90s it was a huge event it
was years and years of hype and people
wandering on the internet what it would
be like and I think that movie kind of
showed the way movies were going to be
going like what movie releases would be
like in the next 20 years you you
mentioned the idea that because we
didn't have a phone in our pockets and
Netflix and all this that helped this
happens so is there no hope for 20 29
men no I have a lot of I mean I thought
last year was I think the last two years
have been extraordinary movie years I
mean I would my biggest hope is that
someone would look at this book and go
I'm gonna write the next best movie or
ever and it is 20 19 or it is 20 29
there's a lot of really exciting
going on right just in a word favorite
one from 99 is election all right whoo
the book is we don't have time for more
I'm sorry the book is the best movie
you're ever it comes out on Tuesday
Brian thanks so much so much guys